so i'd like to thank madad and the
mcgovern organizers for the
um invitation to participate today
um it is a privilege and if i'm honest
also somewhat of a surprise
to find myself promoted albeit for a day
to the lofty world of
neural models um nevertheless i shall
try and
join this throng so what we've been
interested in for some time now
are the systems and circuits that
enable animals to act on demand to
extract
information from the sensory world that
surrounds them
to store it if necessary and to
transform that
for the purpose of
behavior through movement and
as this slide from little scribble from
giacomo balla
the italian futurist
indicates um in mammals some of the most
sophisticated motor behaviors that the
neural systems have to accommodate
are to do with the movement of limbs
from
seem to be meta-stable
sorry for this
so
let's go
great so what balor is describing here
in locomotion is the avoidance of
obstacles and in reaching is object
manipulation
and somehow the circuits that control
movement have to accommodate these
diverse um
motor tasks and one way of you know
conceiving of this that many people have
suggested is to place that in
some sort of sensory recipient world so
the idea would be that a motor plan
sends a series of commands which result
in motor output
eventually there is the validation of
that motor command through sensory
feedback
in a recipient system which updates the
motor plan
and it's been commented by many people
that
this simple reflex sensory circuitry
is burdened with many constraints and
challenges
some of which are demonstrated or shown
here so
this comes from the world of primate and
human
motor control where individuals are
moving
particularly through arm movements
looking at the variability
and so some of these constraints are
demonstrated here in the form of
the variability of sensory input
proprioceptive
sensory neurons are subject to massive
changes in firing rate and somehow the
central nervous system has to
accommodate that
the transformation of motor output to
sensory feedback
is associated with delays
that will tend to destabilize output
systems
and then finally one has to accommodate
the idea that
during a single motor act the strategies
needed to accommodate biomechanical
constraints and fatigue and other things
have to change rather dramatically over
time
and the approach that we have been
taking is simply to ask
whether probing the underlying
organization of neural circuits that are
thought to
control these different motor mechanisms
might provide any insight into
the constraints challenges and
principles of motor control and so
in work that i'm not going to talk about
the variability of sensory input
has been demonstrated to be subject to
a an inhibitory constraint exerted
directly
on the pre-synaptic sensory neurons
i'm going to spend a little time talking
about circuits for delay that
accommodate delays
and that are involved in changes in
motor strategy
over time so let's begin with the delay
problem
um here and so many people have
argued that there are one of the
solutions to the delay in
sensory feedback that delays incurred by
muscle contraction for example
but also felt throughout the sensory
recipient side of things
can be overcome by introducing an
internal copy
of the motor command that feeds in in
many cases
two systems that are involved in
predicting as you heard a little bit
from nate the
sensory consequences of predicted motor
acts
and so the challenge here is to try and
find
aspects of circuitry that relate to
these
imputed internal
copy pathways and so there are many
designs of these internal copies you can
imagine
i want to focus on just one of them here
which is where
instead of providing parallel inputs to
a recipient system
and to the motor output in this case a
single neuron
assumes both features of providing a
pre-motor
output as well as relaying some other
internal input into um
the recipient pathway in the form of a
single neuron that is branched with one
descending
and one ascending axon and the reason
for thinking that this sort of
circuit might have relevance has come
from work that was originated by anders
lundberg and has been continued by broad
altermark
in the context of propriospinal neurons
in the spinal cord
and so what also mark and
lundberg first described is that it's
cervical levels of the spinal cord
they're so-called propriospinal neurons
one branch of which projects onto motor
neurons
and contributes to the process of motor
excitation
a second branch which will project the
lateral reticular nucleus
a relay station on route to the
cerebellum
and since things like forward models are
often inferred to
exist within cerebellar structures this
raised the possibility that proprio
spinal neurons might have something to
do
with this internal copy of motor control
and there is some evidence in cats and
primates
that that might be true from these sorts
of classical experiments
carried out by broad also mark where one
lesions
the primo to branch of appropriate
spinal neuron
and then show that in this case in cats
that animals have reaching defects they
overshoot they undershoot
and the normal fidelity of a reaching
grass through a food pellet
is seriously degraded there but this is
really tantamount to saying that we've
lost a premotor input and it doesn't
really
interrogate the internal copy component
of that bifurcating neuron
and so with this background i'm a nazim
a postdoctoral fellow in the lab
has teamed up with raw aston mart to try
to see whether we can gain access into
this general set of problems in mice
by first of all trying to delineate
genetically
this set of propriospinal neurons and
then manipulate them in various ways and
test their involvement
particularly focusing on this internal
branch
that provides input to the lateral
reticular nucleus
and so the features appropriate spinal
neurons described in the cat
has them predominantly forming an
ipsilateral projection
and then projecting as a last order
excitatory input
to motor neurons via the release of
glutamate and if one compares
those two features with the known
subtypes of interneurons that we've been
defining in the spinal cord
on the basis of projection pattern and
transmitter phenotype there's only one
class that
corresponds to this group and they're
the so-called v2a
interneurons which can be defined
molecularly
by expression of the transcription
factor checks 10.
so this permitted iron to try a set of
experiments to ask where the v2a neurons
have the anatomical features
of the propriospinal neurons described
in cat and in monkey and so
we made a chex 10 transgenic mouse
expressing pre-recombinase
and then in that background if we inject
an adeno-associated virus
expressing a fluxed fluorescent
protein derivative there and ask
whether the neurons that project to
motor neurons also project to the
lateral reticular nucleus you can see a
very dense terminal yfp expression
in the lateral reticular nucleus but
this could still mean that some neurons
project to lrn some to motor neurons
then they're not
one and the same and so irman did a
further experiment where
he crossed in um a yfp reporter
there so that we can identify individual
yfp
positive v2a neurons and then asked if
they have
an individual neuron has a projection to
the lrn by doing stereotactic injection
of ctb and getting retrograde tracing
and also by injecting wheat germa
glutamine into individual fallen muscles
so that it's
transported retrogradedly trans
synaptically
and then it labels the same neuron and
so in this way you can build up the fact
that
individual v2a neurons project both to
motor neurons and to the lateral
reticular nucleus
and we estimate and it's probably an
underestimate that somewhere around 30
to 40 percent of these neurons comprise
these anatomical features
so with this and the ability to express
channel rhodopsin in these neurons
through this genetic entry point
we can now ask whether activation of pn
neurons is sufficient to drive
lateral reticular neurons an essence
an essential component of trying to test
the function of these neurons
in some internal copy pathway and so the
way that um
iron did this is to express channel
rhodopsin
in these neurons in the same transgenic
background
and then insert a small light probe
into the lateral reticular nucleus so
that we can activate the terminals of
these neurons by
selective photo stimulation and
appropriate wavelength
record from lrn neurons identify those
lrn neurons as
projecting to the cerebellum by
antidramic spike activation there
turn the light on at this wavelength and
see in
lrn neurons the synaptic consequence of
activation these pn terminals and we
know the identity of these neurons
because there is a spike collision here
after cerebellar stimulation so this
says that
activating pn terminals is sufficient
to drive lrn activity a first
prerequisite
but in these studies we
iman and raw spend a long time trying to
establish that activation of the
terminal doesn't lead to the propagation
of an antidramic spike that then passes
the cell body
and would then activate the pre-motor
input
and so the idea here is to record this
time from pn
neurons we can activate the pn neurons
with
direct electrical stimulation of the
lateral reticular nucleus and pn
terminals
but turning the light on never ever ever
gave us
any response in these neurons so for
reasons that
remain convenient but still obscure
activating terminals produces a one-way
transmission where we activate the lrn
system and don't produce a direct primo
to activation
so then the ability to selectively
activate this
pre this internal copy arm suggested
what behavioral experiments could we do
to try and test the impact of selective
internal copy activation
and influenced by experiments in cat and
monkey eiman developed
a reaching assay a goal-directed
reaching assay in mice
in which mice are placed
separated from a food pellet by a
perspex barrier
and then asked to reach through that
barrier
and then with high-speed video cameras
we determined the kinematic trajectory
and velocity of these reaches i'll just
show you that again
um since it went off so here is a mouse
with a reflective
palette marker on the paw reaching for
this target
and you can see here a relatively linear
trajectory and we can monitor the
velocity and several other parameters
of this feature and so then what happens
um under these conditions
if we inactivate or we activate the pn
system we've done both
inactivation of v2a neurons and shown
reaching defects using this assay
and what happens if we selectively
activate this internal copy branch
and so here we're doing this before
turning the pn terminal activation
system on
and then looking afterwards which is
plotted here
what you can see is activation
selectively of this
internal copy branch produces a severe
discoordination in the normal linearity
of reach trajectory
and in the velocity and every time you
stimulate
you see um the same defect in trajectory
there
so in some way here activation of this
internal copy branch has led
to motor defects inactivation of v2a
neurons as a population
leads to reaching defects supporting the
idea that in some way this system
is involved in motor control
and so we iman has been now interested
in
how activation of pn terminals
activating lrn neurons
then leads to this perturbation
of motor behavior and so
the idea that um
he's been examining is that activation
of this system by
recruiting lrn neurons which projected
the cerebellum
produces a relatively direct
feedback control that can be sensed by
recording from motor neurons following
pn terminal activation so what happens
when you turn the light on while
recording
from motor neurons and what you find
is that there's a relatively short
latency
response recorded in motor neurons
following pn
terminal activation in lrn so about
three to four milliseconds after the
onset of activation here we see motor
neuron responses so that is a
quick response there which we imagine
is not mediated by cerebellar cortex
directly but may involve the
activation of deep cerebellar nuclei
that would then activate the reticular
spinal system and come back and project
down to the spinal cord so this response
system here
is sufficiently rapid to explain the
defects in trajectory
on the duration of the reach that we can
monitor with kinematics here
and we have some evidence that this
really does reflect the output
of the lrn to the cerebellum because if
we
now lesion the lrn cerebellar output
system
the amplitude of these motor responses
this time recorded as field potential
is decreased to the order of about 70
percent
so this supports the idea that the lrn
projections to the cerebellum
initiates a rapid motor response which
then is exerted in terms
of um both physiology and perturbations
in behavior
so in this system what i think has
emerged
is that the proper spinal neurons in
mouse
provide are capable of providing a
direct motor command through their
pre-motor input there
but also serve to activate this
lrn sensory receiving system on the way
to the cerebellum
and then can in a sense in one neuron
link output and sensory input
now there are many issues that we don't
understand
in analysis of this system one is that
presumably this is an excitatory neuron
that activates the motor neuron
yet the consequences of activating the
internal copy
are to reinforce that activation where
you might expect perhaps
to see the opposite negative
cancellation sign based on the things
that
nate has been telling you and so the
basis of this reinforcing loop may
reflect the fact that in fact
there's not just single one single
population of p
n neurons silvia arbor's lab has
provided evidence
for many different pn populations some
excitatory
some inhibitory and we don't understand
the activation
of those neurons in any detail and it
may be that there are degrees of muscle
specificity
that is that when you activate in real
circuitry
you're activating highly specific
subsets of this generic circuit that
we've engaged
and so what iman is doing at the moment
is trying to
first of all test the endogenous
conditions
physiologically for recruitment of these
neurons
by expressing various genetically
encoded
calcium indicators and monitoring in the
lrn
the conditions in motor actions that are
sufficient to recruit pns which is an
essential first step
and then to try various methods ideally
not just for activating this arm but for
inactivating the arm
and looking at the consequences in terms
of adaptive features of motor control
so this is one example of a genetically
defined circuit
that can then begin to be hopefully
picked apart in some further detail
for the last part of this talk what i'd
like to do is switch to the second
issue that we've been trying to
understand in terms of
um underlying circuitry and that is
this idea that motor acts
are shaped to meet the tasks
at hand you have a fixed set of motives
a fixed set of muscles
and you're born with that and somehow
you have to negotiate the vast
repertoire of motor possibilities that
exist in the world around you so the
idea
in this system here is to look at the
way in which strategies for motor
activation
change over time so the idea would be
that the
um appropriate motor acts early
in a motor plan would be different from
those late
and how can we understand that at the
level of circuitry
and in order to introduce this problem i
want to go back a hundred years to the
sheratonian view of limb motor
coordination
and that is this idea of at
limb joints are flexion and extension
as opponent antagonistic alternating
systems
so for example when you are flexing
you activate falling muscles which are
different from those muscles that are
activating
an extension and sheraton had the
foresight
to come up with one feature of the
circuitry that drives this capacity for
limb alternation and that is the sensory
afferent feedback that is for example
providing
excitatory input to a flexor motor
neuron
is at the same time ensuring the
quiescence of the extensor motor neurone
by recruiting an intervening inhibitory
interneuron so this reciprocal
inhibitory interneuron is
at the core of the alternation program
and then in the passage of time there
have to be
ways of inactivating this inhibitory
neuron we know that one of those
neurons is the wrenching interneuron
found in the ventral spinal cord that in
part has a motor
collateral recruitment system so this is
the classical view
promoted by sherrington of alternation
but we also know that there are certain
motor acts and sensory feedback systems
both reflexive and voluntary that favor
a different
view of co-activation or co-contraction
in fact the first
people who ever sort of articulated this
alternative view
were a neurologist and a physiologist at
columbia so i felt compelled to follow
their lead some 90 years ago and so
one of the motor acts that favors
co-activation
is the act of balancing on a narrow beam
or the act of maintaining your ankle at
a
tight physical fidelity so um in work by
arthur prahashka
as individuals are to balance on
tightropes or narrow beams
and you record physiologically you see a
much greater extent of co-activation
similarly yensbo nielsen's group in
denmark recorded
muscle activities from ballerinas in the
danish royal ballet
and here at the ankle you get
co-activation
of flexes and extensors for dramatic
periods of time
so the issue is how can you understand
the circuitry that can modulate
these transitions from alternation to
co-activation
presumably their internal systems that
are directing that at will in the
central nervous system
so andrew murray in the lab has tried to
emulate the idea that
acts that involve balance and the
vestibular system
may be involved in triggering
and we can measure these changes in
motor strategy
and so what andy has been doing is
training mice to walk on a narrow
balance beam
and then introducing a vestibular
activating perturbation
by deflecting the beam at the same time
monitoring the position of the animal on
the balance beam and also doing emg
recordings to look at the nature of
transitions
so i'll just show you the basic assay
system
the mouse is walking along there's a
small perturbation
laterally and the mouse does a pretty
good job of maintaining its posture so
here
in this tail reflector we're seeing that
it manages to maintain his position
on that balance beam despite the
perturbation that activates the
vestibular system
and when you record from emg studies of
individual antagonist muscles at
different joints in the limb
you see something interesting too that
so these are extensors these are flexor
muscles here
so here early on after the perturbation
you see extensor activity in all three
joints
and no evidence for flexor activity and
that is
charted here quantitatively but then
some 10 or 20 milliseconds later
you see a period of co-activation both
of flexors and extensor so this
vestibular stimulus much as in humans
is producing an initial asymmetric
extensor specific
activation followed by a co-activation
phase now this of course doesn't prove
that the vestibular system is in any way
involved it could be the response of
proprioceptors in the limb that are
achieving this
so andy designed a set of experiments to
lesion that part of the vestibular
system that is projecting to the hind
limb
the lateral vestibular nucleus in the
mouse and see if it had any impact as
the first
experiment so the way that he did that
is to use an adeno-associated virus
diphtheria
toxin receptor stereotactic injection
then sometime later to inject diphtheria
toxin selectively
in the lumbar spinal cord so that it's
only taken up by the axons of lvn
neurons that project to the lumbar
spinal cord
and then after diphtheria toxin exposure
monitor the number of neurons in the lvn
by a fluorogold injection sometime later
and the basic upshot of this is that
these stereotactic injections combined
with
lumbar diphtheria toxin administration
produce a 75 to 80 percent deletion of
lvn neurons in a selective way
the medial vestibular nucleus is not
affected under these conditions
so does this have any impact in terms of
motor control systems so here is a mouse
now
after a lesion
and you can see i hope that it has a
much harder job clinging on to that
balance beam and that is quantified here
so we see some sign of um
you know a motor behavioral impairment
under lvn
ablation rather as in humans and if you
look at the emg
what you see and i'm just showing you
one um a knee joint system here
that the amplitude of the early extensor
specific responses
severely decreased and there's also a
corresponding
loss in the late co-activation so the
vestibular nucleus is
involved in this process and in a sense
it argues that there are three phases
of um transition in motor response an
early extensor-specific
activation something that we call a
priming step
where something has to change in order
to permit co-activation
and the late co-activation step and in
some ways this is similar to
views based on human motor control for
example
steve scott's emphasis on
optimal feedback control not optical
feedback control here
where you get short latency reflexive
responses
and then longer latency responses which
can be separated
by the nature of the input stimulus
so we've been interested in trying to
understand the underlying
elements of spinal circuitry that
underlie
this transition from alternation to
co-activation
first dealing with the early basis of
extensor specific
activation and so what andy did
is to use an anatomical labeling
technique in which we
introduce a rabies virus which can be
retrogradedly transported into the
presynaptic terminals trans synaptically
into either extensor or flector muscles
and simply measure the number of neurons
in the lvn
and what you find is the only time you
see labeled lateral
lvn neurons is when you inject into
extensor muscles and never into flexor
muscles here
so the basis of extensor specificity
seems to be that the lvn neurons
selectively innervate extensor motor
neurons accounting for this early
activation
and this agrees with older physiological
studies that stem grillner
and toshinora hongo performed in the cat
so this explains the basis
of the early response the asymmetric
response
so the most interesting step in my view
is this next
priming response the middle time period
where you have to
arguably overcome the impact of the
dominance
of this reciprocal inhibitory
interneuronal synapse
so how could that be achieved it's been
known and as i mentioned
that rental neurons provide one input
two reciprocal inhibitory neurons and
andy murray has shown using anatomy that
about half the renshaw neurons
themselves receive a direct input from
the lateral
vestibular nucleus so this provides a
rapid anatomical substrate for
activation of lnvn neurons to activate
renshaw to inhibit
which would then presumably lead to the
possibility of co-activation
so these are anatomical studies that
have led
to circuit wiring diagrams how can we
test
the impact of any of these systems
functionally in terms of motor control
and so
we can try and drive this core circuitry
towards
um alternation it's certain
manipulations i'm going to concentrate
on the drive to co-activation
so you would predict that if we
inhibited
or inactivated this 1a reciprocal
inhibitory into neuron
it would then reduce
alternation and increase the drive to
co-activation and we're trying to do
that with markers for interneuron
subtypes
what we could also conceive is that
we could fool the system into
switching the sign of this interneuron
from inhibition to excitation producing
a constitutive reciprocal excitation
and we've managed to do that and examine
the consequences
in terms of limb motor coordination so
this is really
testing in a sense the sharingtonian
view
of the dominance of reciprocal
inhibition in this system
and the way that we've done that and
this is the work of david ing
is to make use of the fact that this is
a glycenergic
with a little bit of gaba thrown in
inhibitory transmitter system
that the chloride equilibrium potential
then determines the response of cells
to activation of these glycine or gaba
receptors
under normal conditions by virtue of the
kcc2 extrusion pump
intracellular chloride is low so you
activate the receptor
you come in a chloride rushes in and you
get an ipsp
if we inactivated this chloride
extrusion pump there then chloride
is found at high concentrations in the
cell you activate the same receptor
now chloride rushes out and you don't
depolarize the system
so david used that logic to inactivate
kcc2 selectively in motor neurons and
then ask the consequences in terms of
limb motor control and so i'm going to
show you two image or two movies now
one of the young mouse in which kcc2 has
been inactivated selectively in motor
neurons
and you can see the limbs are extended
there the mouse is not
paralyzed but its limbs are hyper
activated
in an extended mode consistent with the
idea of co-activation
and this phenotype gets worse with time
so if we look
at an older mouse here
you can see that the mouse is relatively
immobile
and it's immobile and it's resting on
its tiptoes there
so every joint is activated maximally
under these conditions and it simply
cannot move
either left right coordination or at
individual joints
and if we record the emg from knee
antagonists at those conditions
we see a dramatic evidence for
co-activation
of joints that normally are operating so
this
i think supports the idea that
this reciprocal inhibitory synapse is
dominant
and is important in determining the
degree
of alternation co-activation equilibrium
and we're now trying to examine in other
ways um
how this system really controls that
transition between alternation and
co-activation
and so what we're trying to do now in
the future because we have and i haven't
gone through this
markers from many different subtypes of
engineering
rental cells other small subpopulations
in principle we can inactivate the
rental cell
see if that drives you towards the
alternation mode
inactivate eventually the 1a inhibitory
neuron see if it drives you in the
opposite direction on that continuum
there
and hopefully build up a greater degree
of confidence in the circuit diagrams
that are mediating these different
vestibular descending inputs
the other thing that is strongly implied
by these results
is a heterogeneity of lvn neurons
themselves the simplest way of thinking
about this
is that the early response involves a
set of lvn neurons
that activate elements of a spinal motor
circuitry
that are different from those that are
needed to suppress the wrenching
cells or to activate the reticular
spinal system that we think has got a
lot to do with this late phase of
co-activation so if we could find
molecular correlates of these three
populations
we would then be able to predict the
motor consequences of activation of
these three different populations and
we're trying to
do that extensively at the moment so i
just want to finish with this
idea that we can take a systems level
plan of um
output and its sensory feedback and
slowly
pick apart different elements of that
system at the synaptic and neuronal
level
the pre-synaptic gaiting that i didn't
talk about this internal copy system
that eyman has been studying
and then this switching strategy for
alternation
and co-activation that is so important
in
controlling many aspects of motor
behavior so i will stop there
just highlight the people who've done
the work hyman really led
the appropriate spinal neuron project
iman's here in the audience so i would
encourage you to find him and pester him
about more details of that
andrew murray has been leading the
vestibular alternation
co-activation project david ing has been
trying to manipulate chloride currents
and we've been getting a lot of advice
in this system from yensbo nielsen a
human physiologist in denmark
who in a remarkable way predicted
many of the involvements of renshaw
cells and 1a
into neurons on the basis of human
studies and i still don't quite know how
he managed to do that but
everything we are doing is really a
reflection and testing of these human
physiological studies so i'll stop there
thank you very much